in exactly one hour from now
a series of blasts will bring this place
to the ground
if anyone tries to enter or negotiate
with me
i will kill everyone
where's your dad
kyle i know your wife left you but i
think you need to find your purpose
doing the best i can
being kind of dangerous out there these
days it's an election year
and my customers are my voters and not
the president
yeah but you're on your way down
everyone this is the one and only
sam nelson
let's do this
[Applause]
attention shoppers i am wearing a
suicide vest
you hear me sam nelson you belong to me
i'm going to destroy everything you love
sam
uncle luther rotted away in prison and
somebody's got to pay
everything's going to be all right jesus
kyle
what's marine always a marine
what is this it's hot find it
how y'all doing i'm a product of chaos
looking for you all we know is to kill
you
we will find you i know you're here
let's go soldier
you admit to what you did all these
people died
you